this is a production of Cornell
University
well it's always awesome to come come
here because there's so many plant
biologists you know I exist in an
environment where I'm usually talking to
people with an MD rather than a pH
degree so today I'm going to give some
real botany about maize anthers and then
we're going to see how the new class of
small RNAs called fazzy rnase influence
anther development so first I want to
tell you how to build an anther so in
maize there are three floret primordia
and these little bumps are going to be
the stamens and these statement initials
basically use up most of the meristem
and there's cells derived from the l1
layer of the meristem and from both of
the l2 layers of monocot meristem and
there's about a hundred cells at the
beginning in each of these statement
initials and what's really remarkable to
me is that nine days later at the start
of meiosis we've built each anther into
this four lobe structure subtended by a
filament which contains the vascular
column which proceeds up through the
center of each anther and there's now
about 50,000 cells so the pace of cell
division and anthers is cell division
about every eight hours which is faster
than the million cells in tissue culture
and also there's patterning so from
these meristem drive letters within each
lobe we end up with an epidermis from
the l1 and for cell types from this sub
epidermal layer the endothelium which is
colored green because it actually has
chloroplasts the middle layer of more or
less unknown function the two petal
cells which are nutritive cells for the
Archos poriyal than pollen mother cells
and Maya sites and later the micro
gametophyte
so we need to have a fast pace of cell
division but the first question we
really asked was where do the cell types
how do you get started
making an answer and the old model was
that there was a primary large cell
called the hypodermis cells it is how to
borrowed from earn reproduction and that
this giant layer two cell would divide
to make a somatic cell to the exterior
and anarchist boreal a prebiotic cell to
the interior and this is actually copied
from my undergraduate botany notes it
made no sense to me because the next
drawing the teacher made was this where
we have a ring of soma around that
central reproductive cell and that just
doesn't seem very likely and so rather
than using transverse sections which
everyone had done up to that point we
switch to using confocal microscopy so
we could make a more robust description
of what was going on and in the early
anther here's the incipient four lobes
when you do it by confocal you can never
find the giant cell but in this one
transverse image from the confocal
probably everyone can pick out a cell
that looks bigger but when you actually
do all the volumes there is no giant
cell instead what happens is there's
continual division kind of in any plane
now we're looking at a longitudinal view
of a small anther until their cells that
only have l2d neighbors so before that
every l2d cell touched in a presumptive
epidermal cell but this white dot shows
you a cell that is completely surrounded
now by l2d cells and that event which
you can image in in any view combined
with a specific glute or a dachshund
called Miska one and I'll tell you later
hypoxia which is transduced through this
glute of a dachshund causes cells like
this to greatly enlarge and become the
artists Oriole cells so the first type
of cell that specif
in an anther lobe is actually the pre my
OTT Excel the Argos Oriole cell and
these cells then secrete a small protein
ligand called Mac wine that causes the
differentiation of the soma so there
isn't a special hypodermis cell at the
beginning there's a sequence of events
that results in specification and that
process takes approximately a day to
make a column of our carcass royal cells
down the length of the anther and this
also solves an old question in flowering
plant biology in the hypodermis cell
model all of the pollen grains from one
lobe would have had one progenitor cell
so in maize at least there's 10 to 12 of
these progenitors no the anther is
growing quickly at this point and that
occurs by primarily by anticlinal
divisions that add length and girth to
the anther but an extremely important
job of these artists Oriole cells is to
secrete knack one and that causes the
l2d neighbor the cell that's just
sub-epidermal to undergo a peri clinal
division setting up the endothelium
which is the layer adjacent to the
epidermis and a sub epidermal cell
called the secondary parietal cell this
cell will later divide Perry Cline early
to make the middle layer in the 2p dome
so one of our discoveries after kind of
figuring out the sequence of events in
ontogeny was that environmental
conditions actually trigger the
specification of that artists Oriole
cell and it's hypoxia is the
environmental trigger so this was not
quite a guess the graduate student
involved Tim Kelleher had done a lot of
RNA analysis transcriptome analysis and
in the early days of that let's go back
to 2010 or so what you ended up was huge
piles of data and no insight
but what paid off was a long long time
ago I had worked on hypoxic roots and
when I looked at the transcriptome of
these very immature answers I saw all
the signature that I had seen in in
young root tissue that was exposed to
excess water so we used an oxygen
electrode that's contained inside this
26 gauge needle to measure the amount of
oxygen in the airspace around the
developing tassel so right when this
specification event occurs the column of
air that's inside the world of maize
leaves out here near the surface it's
close to ambient it goes down down down
because the young leaves are not
photosynthetic they're living off
respiration they're sucking the air the
oxygen out of this air and so around the
tassel it's down at 1.4 percent oxygen
for about three days and that's enough
to cause the specification of that
column of our tutorial cells and we went
on to do experimental tests of that by
using tiny needles or hoses threaded
down the column of air and we attached
the hoses to either an oxygen tank or a
nitrogen tank so we could add lots of
extra oxygen or purge it all out with
nitrogen making it super hypoxic and
this is kind of a complicated slide but
the punchline is that if you use
nitrogen that is make it more hypoxic
you get precocious and extra argus
Floreal cells in fact violating one of
the fundamentals of botany we could
convert epidermal cells to pre mitotic
cells if we applied the hypoxia severely
oxygen delays the specification if we
look at just this graph importantly
though here in green is what happens
with nitrogen so precocious and
seemingly extra but it tops out at the
same point as control or the oxygen
treatment so the process is
self-regulating Yuwen
at the same point even if you're delayed
by adding oxygen and the key event here
is the arcus boreal cell specification
they act through this Mac one small
molecule on these sub-epidermal l2d
cells converting them to primary
parietal cells those cells then undergo
the peri clonal division that sets up
the two somatic cell types okay so this
ontogeny was very satisfying in terms of
an explanation but we had still many
many questions about Mac one so we knew
from experiments I'm not showing that
it's a secreted protein it's processed
to a smaller form and things like that
but a lot of things we couldn't
determine for example when Argos boreal
cells secrete this protein does it act
globally or does it act locally so in
plant biology we're often thinking of
hormones say in the vasculature and then
they arrive someplace and they influence
a lot of cells it's important to keep in
mind that these anther lobes have no
meristem there is no organizing center
so this small molecule being secreted by
a newly specified it cell could be a
type of organizing Center a type of
organizing molecule so all of these
questions sort of haunted us and the way
that we solved it at least in part was
to convert a pathogen we've worked with
called oyster legume a dose it's a
fungal pathogen pathogen that's a bio
troph it doesn't kill or even enter maze
cells so when it hits am a cell it
causes the plasma membrane of the may
cell to imaginate so that the fungal
hypha is inside this a plastic space and
we engineered gusta la go to secrete the
Mac one protein under a booster logo
promoter that acts on the second and
third day after infection so that was
enough time for the fungus to get
sub-epidermal a
and be in contact with those Ltd cells
so the important experiment was to apply
this special strain which we call a
Trojan horse because it's delivering a
secret package the Mac one protein to
the walls the apple plastics base of the
plant was to ask what happens in a Mac
one mutant so this is a schematic it's
actually a tracing of a confocal image
of what a fertile anther looks like at
this stage there's artists poriyal cells
there's sub epidermal cells and then
there's the epidermis and over here in
Mac one there's epidermis and sub
epidermal cells and Argos Oriole cells
but we've colored them differently
because there's just one layer and and
here there's two layers because the peri
clonal division has occurred now when we
in fact with a control strain of boost a
logo that has no cargo other than a
fluorescent protein we can track the
hyphy inside maze and these arrows point
to regions that have that bio trophic
interface and what's nifty about the bio
trophic interface is it's approximately
the same width as the space between a
typical arcus foreo cell and its
putative somatic neighbour so we're kind
of recreating the distance that the
protein would have to travel here's the
Trojan horse train it makes a similar
number of by atrophic interfaces and we
could find in the fun G both thee as
made from the gene and the process
secreted form of the protein and the
most amost important assay was how often
are there additional cells that are
penetrated by the L 2 D cell that then
or where the fungal hyphae have made
this intimate association that have gone
undergone the peri clonal division and
in the control strain it's really low
under 10% but when you have the Trojan
horse it's about 60% so way
more than half of the penetrated cells
that received the Mac one protein
underwent the peri clean revision but no
neighbor cell ever did it so it means
that the Mac one signal is cell
autonomous it's secreted by an artist
Oriole cell and it has to act on a
recipient cell presumably there's a
receptor and we later cloned receptor
it's a homolog of the rice msp1 receptor
and there's no signaling between these
l2d cells that say oh I saw Mac one so
you should do this you're my neighbor
each cell needs to get the signals
separately now in addition to defining
this positive signal we also defined a
repressive signal it's controlled by an
epidermal transcription factor called OC
l4 and it makes a mobile signal and
we'll learn more about what the identity
of that might be later in the seminar
and it suppresses extra sub-epidermal ie
endo these--all peri clonal divisions so
in the ocl for mutant instead of having
just one layer of sub epidermal
endothelial cells you have two layers in
half of the sphere you might say of the
lobe it's the outer like the northern
hemisphere basically in the Mac one
mutant when it's just Mac one you have
lots and lots of extra artists Oriole
cells because the soma isn't specified
and it basically stops dividing so the
central space as the anther grows just
fills with pre mitotic cells when you
make the double mutant the sub epidermal
cells in the absence of whatever ocl for
does undergo a peri clonal division so
there's two controls of this really
important setup of the soma one is an
activating signal the Mac one ligand and
the other is a repressive signal and
that's become a common theme in in
developmental biology if you apply the
gas
more of something you also need to have
brakes and make sure that you can stop
it in time so this is a review slide now
so if there was going to be an exam I
would hear all the four color pens in
the room click summarizing what we've
learned
so we initiate Arcos poriyal
specification by hypoxia which is
naturally imposed by the way that corn
grows and it acts through miss Kawana
glue to read oxen in the Miska one you
know Argos for oil sells are specified
okay once they are they're shown in
purple they secrete Mack one and they
convert their neighbor Ltd sells one at
a time to primary parietal cells and the
job of those PPC cells is to divide peri
finally to make the secondary parietal
layer and the endothelium and then ocl
for acts from the epidermis to prevent
these green cells from dividing peri
cleanly again so that's a good review I
hope you're up-to-date now about Bayes
anthers it turns out ocl 4 has another
job and that is it controls the
production of 21 nucleotide bazi RNAs
these fazzy rnase the biogenesis factors
are localized in the epidermis exactly
where the ACL for transcription factor
localizes but the fazzy RNAs are small
and they accumulate throughout the soma
of the anther lobe they could be the
mobile signal that suppresses peri
clonal division we don't know that for
sure but that's our working hypothesis
so before sort of talking more about
that hypothesis I think I need to tell
you a bit what fozzy RNAs are so we
discovered these in 2006 working with
cinders lab at UC Davis he was working
on rice we were working on corn and Lou
Bowman came from Clemson University to
do some work in my lab and he was an
expert on small RNA and
boom we had all these small rnas we were
so miss defied by them we didn't publish
for three years so I mean for graduate
students don't despair like when you
don't if you don't understand something
sometimes it's better to wait anyway we
waited for a few years and then we
published and the the reason that these
small RNAs were mysterious I know it
recall that the Carrington lab and
others had I then found tazzy RNA
strands acting small interfering RNAs
and was that kind of a forest of
different small interfering RNAs
particularly in plants the hallmark of
each and every one of those is it had an
mRNA target our problem is the fazzy
RNAs have no targets that you can
identify in the transcriptome so they do
not match a messenger RNA they have some
other function and just to confess now
that's still the state of the art
although we have some guesses about what
they might be doing okay so now you'll
want to know how to make one of these so
for those of you who are affiliate
familiar with the biogenesis of
transacting silencing RNA s but the sort
of steps are really similar but there's
different players so for the twenty one
nucleotide Fozzie's in maze there's
approximately four hundred and forty
different loci and they make a long
non-coding RNA that gets capped and
polyadenylated just like an mrna this
molecule is then bound by an Argonaut
and Argonaut one that's carrying a micro
RNA called two one one eight and we just
discovered and it's unpublished and
likely to be unpublished for a while
that this complex is actually bound to a
ribosome bound to ribosomes I should say
poly somes and that almost all of the
Fazle site contained short Orff's so the
short orphe
ensures loading onto the ribosome so it
does
you might say like a messenger RNA we
have yet to find any of the peptide
predicted peptides though so we're not
sure if they're translated or they could
have a very short half-life anyway on
the ribosome there is cleavage by the
micro RNA - one one eight right here and
almost simultaneous copying by reverse
transcriptase Rd R six that makes the
second strand of RNA and then Dicer for
attaches to this double stranded region
and precisely chops it starting at the
five prime end into twenty one
nucleotide double stranded segments only
one of which is typically preserved so
that's a little bit mysterious and these
retained small RNAs are bound by a go v
c and they constitute the 21 nucleotide
as an RNA population know the 24
nucleotide fasces have a very similar
ontogeny but they have a different
specific micro RNA they have a different
region of complementarity than these
guys to a specific micro RNA they're
copied by rd r6 but then a novel dice
earth that's basically monocot specific
the gene duplication from Dicer 3 dates
back about 80 million years so this is
Paula and some closely related families
Dicer 5 chops it into 24 nucleotide
small RNAs and we don't yet know what
Argonaut finds those small RNAs it makes
a large population of 24 nucleotide
Pazzis so a typical precursor generates
between 20 and 50 small rnas each and
the reason that we discovered them so
long ago when methods were really crude
is these guys are unbelievably abundant
and they also show very distinct
temporal deployment in anthers they are
anther specific in the power
in other plants they are at least floral
specific they might be anther specific
that people haven't dissected answers to
demonstrate that so back here at 0.2
millimeter is right when the Argos
Oriole cells are being specified and 0.4
is when the somatic cells specification
has finished and most of the cells the
primary parietal cells have undergone
the parry clinal division that sets up
and to feast him and the secondary
parietal and here's the 21 nucleotide
Bazzi micro RNA right here so you can
see it's made a little bit a for the 0.4
stage but it Peaks here here's the faz
low sy so they're incredibly abundant at
0.4 from barely there and here's the
proportion of all 21 nucleotide small
RNAs including all the micro RNAs that
are actually fazzy so at 0.4
approximately 65% of all 21 nucleotide
RNAs are faz er is and the proportion
declines over time but they're retained
through mid meiosis at reasonably
abundant levels no for the 24 nucleotide
phase low sy there's a tiny bit of
transcript production and small RNA
production early but the Big Bang so to
speak of setting up the precursors and
the micro RNA that are required starts
at one millimeter which is the
transition between artists for L cells
and POW and mother cells if you're
tracking the germinal cells and is also
as I'll point out in more detail later a
time when the 2p tamari differentiates
and then peak abundance of the 24
nucleotide Fozzie's occurs at 2
millimeters which is late prophase 1
towards the end could be the end of
meiosis 1 when there are close to 70
percent of all the 24 nucleotide small
RNAs
so these guys were easy to find even
with crude methods if you dissected
anthers of the right stage and the
amount of them is millions of copies per
cell so we're talking about a huge
amount of small RNA we also always track
other types of small RNA those
repressors of transposons and has three
types Moll rnase okay so in addition to
temporal separation of now what are two
classes of small RNA as the rnase
there's also spatial separation so i've
already mentioned that the epidermis and
specifically dependent on the ocl for
transcription factor which is
preferentially expressed kind of at the
North Pole sort of a limited arc here on
the outer part of each lobe that's where
the micro RNA - one one eight
predominance predominates and also the
precursor transcripts twenty one faz
although they're sort of found elsewhere
including what we think is artefactual
hybridization - the arcus oriole cells
Dicer for their required cleaving enzyme
is also pretty widely distributed and
for sure the product the 21 nucleotide
Fozzie's are widely distributed in the
anthers we think this and other evidence
that I'm not sharing means that the 21
fat RNAs are mobile we think they start
here and they're spreading into the rest
of the soma now what about the 24
nucleotide Fozzie's we're looking at an
older anther now and the required micro
RNA for cleaving the precursor is highly
enriched in the 2p dome as are the 24
nucleotide faz low sigh as is Dicer 5
the required processing enzyme as are
the 24 nucleotide small rnas
so I know there's one report here from
Cornell from wojtek's lab and one from
Japan I think that has evidence that the
now Pollan mother cells or Maya sites
contain 24 nucleotide fazzy rnase
potentially at a low level but we find
unfortunately that any in-situ probe we
put on especially this stage of anthers
sticks to the kalos code that surrounds
the Maya site so that's very
unsatisfying in terms of knowing whether
it's true or not and then in a separate
study that I'm not talking about today a
postdoc in the lab has purified Arcos
poriyal cells pmc and Maya sites for
single RNA seek and finds neither the
fabs precursors nor Dicer five in those
cells so it remains an open question if
the fazzy rnas are there they're
probably imported from the tip edom
rather than made in situ and then
finally in addition to spatiotemporal
separation the two classes of fazzy rnas
are independently regulated genetically
so i've already pointed out that ocl
four is required to make the 21
nucleotide Pazzis and the micro RNA
levels are greatly reduced the fasces
are virtually gone and almost all the
precursors are gone but the pattern of
24 nucleotide fatty biogenesis is
basically normal and the opposite is
true for Miska one which basically never
gets started so it doesn't have a two
peetam mak one lacks a tepee dome and ms
23 has a very defective two peetam
they're all making the 21 nucleotide
fazzy rnas which are characteristic of
very early stages but they're failing to
make the 24 nucleotide Pazzis the micro
RNA to 275 is made in ms 23 mutants but
it's from a different locus to different
loci
is represented over here so there's
activation of alternative loci but
there's no precursor to process so
there's basically no Fozzie's produced
and a mitotic one which is a mutant that
fails to do a correct meiosis it does
mitosis instead of meiosis in these
pollen mother cells it has both
relatively normal 21 and 24 nucleotide
rnas suggesting that they're not like
stimulators of of meiosis okay so it may
have crossed your mind since I'm amazed
geneticists and we tend to be kind of
narrow-minded that maybe we found
something that's absolutely amazing
specific we used to my seminar at this
point used to talk about how and how
special the grass is where etc but a
couple of smart students in like Myers
lab our collaborators decided to check
non grass monocots and a paper has just
come out in genome for asparagus Lily de
Lille and some other non grass monocots
they all have reproductive as the RNAs
they're also another person in Blake's
lab found their present sporadically in
different families of dicots he was an
expert on lychee like who would both
choose that tree to do the work it turns
out it's easy to get anthers and sure
enough the reproductive aziz were there
and that was followed by collaborators
who supplied strawberry tomato and a
whole lot of other daikon anthers and
sorry to report the one family where
there is zip is the brass of kce so air
bird OPS's is not a model for this and
there's some other major families where
they're extremely rare and then another
place where we should think about these
male specific reproductive small rnas
are the pie rnas that are found in
million testes so these are absolutely
required for successful sperm production
interestingly just like plants there's
two size classes
one is made before meiosis one is made
during meiosis but not in the germinal
cells it's in the supporting cells there
are no known functions because they
don't match messenger rna's so it looks
like convergent evolution to aid male
reproduction in the mammals and the
flowering plants something I find very
odd what is also interesting is we've
worked out the biogenesis mechanisms in
them in the poaceae and there's
different biogenesis mechanisms in the
non grass monocots and in the dicots and
in the mammalian pi rnase so although
you end up with the same types of small
RNA product superabundant it's very
specific times in male reproduction
they're not made in exactly the same way
okay now I'd like to talk in more detail
about the 24 nucleotide disease and
something about the tepee 'dom so tepee
dome is whoops now it's working it's not
weird
oh no it's really bad sorry
you're good with integrating tiny okay
for tippy-toe cell development we've
demonstrated that it's controlled by a
cascade of basic helix-loop-helix
transcription factors starting with the
master regulator male sterile 23 which
acts actually in the secondary parietal
cells and it's important for achieving
the correct peri clonal division and
steps after that
now what's underappreciated is that
capital cells are born and perform a
suite of functions and then during
meiosis they have to read if ur n qi 8
so they're differentiated before meiosis
to do one set of jobs then they read if
ur n she ate four functions late in
meiosis and add even more functions to
support gametophyte s' and all of the
celery differentiation
to require the 24 nucleotide fazzy rnase
and starting with ms 23 is a master
regulator of the chip enum and also as
the master regulator of 24 nucleotide
fazzy RNA biogenesis and it acts in part
through regulating these other of the
HLHS so the production of the correct
micro RNA the precursors the Dicer all
depend on MS 23 now among these various
players many of them are redundant or
partially redundant so there's four low
Sian Corning encoding micro RNA to 275
for example we have a lot of different
Argonauts etc the only thing that was a
single copy gene was Dicer 5 and so we
decided to use CRISPR pass 9 to mutate
this singular gene and find out what
would happen to development of the
anther so it's a honking big gene and we
recovered numerous mutants and for those
not working on maize what's really great
about maize is when we do the
transformation it's of a single cell of
an embryo and culture and it appears
that the CRISPR past 9 system acts in
that cell
so more than 95% of the plants that are
regenerated or by allele it they have
mutations in both alleles independent
mutations and so it's easy to recover
lots of different alleles and we've
characterized carefully four of those
alleles and thank goodness for this even
in the t0 those first initial plants the
Dicer 5 plants are male sterile and I
mean clear male sterility this is what a
tassel looks like that has anthers out
this is a heterozygote of the Dicer 5-1
allele with the wild-type this is a
homozygote Dicer 5-1 and so at the stage
when lots of anthers are out on this
tassel there's nothing out this
and Dicer 5 is absolutely required to
produce the 24 nucleotide fazzy RNAs and
I'll show you that data in the sack
and in all of our early studies the
mutations in Dicer fide conferred male
sterility under field or greenhouse
conditions and it was from Capitola read
differentiation failure so during the
penal cells are there and they've done
some measurable functions normally but
they failed to read if ER n she ate as
secretory cells during meiosis so here's
the demonstration that the 24 nucleotide
Fozzie's which are extremely abundant at
1.5 and even more abundant at 2
millimeters are almost completely gone
in the mutants I have to tell you that
there's a couple of the phase low sigh
that slightly overlap with protein
coding genes and so in the severe
mutants basically what you're seeing is
some small RNA production from the
protein coding genes this is a twelve
nucleotide deletion so four amino acids
and it's a very low function allele and
also important the Dicer v mutation as
expected selectively blocks accumulation
of 24 nucleotide Fozzie's and doesn't
influence the 21 nucleotide fazzy class
it doesn't influence other types of 24
nucleotides small RNA so basically only
orange is super depressed or missing and
the other types of small RNA are normal
and again I'm not showing you all the
data for this but in these mutants the
fast precursors accumulate so the low sy
in this case about 170 loci are still
copiously transcribed and those mRNA
like molecules accumulate because there
is no processing and that's what you'd
expect for a precursor product
relationship okay so obviously we love
to look at anthers it's a microscope and
in looking at the Dicer v mutant at key
stages
from the somatic specification stage
through Pollan mother cell and stages of
meiosis the architecture that is the
cellular anatomy was indistinguishable
between the Dicer v mutant and controls
so we could not find any defect in the
pace or pattern of cell division in the
size of the cells in the number of cells
just seemed the same and we're not
experts at meiosis but this was done by
Han Zhang who was a graduate student in
Kelly DAWs lab where she did learn how
to do all the mitotic staging and again
meiosis appeared to be completely normal
in the Dicer v so we're looking at a
male sterile when we're wondering like
what the heck is wrong with these plants
why why are they male sterile so we need
to kind of return to what goes on in the
tepee 'dom from birth into some of its
specific jobs so in an anther at about
five hundred and fifty microns each lobe
has 600 secondary parietal cells and if
you label with edu which is a tea analog
it's incorporated into DNA it's
non-toxic it's a really great label and
then later you use click at chemistry to
attach a fluorescent label to the edu
molecules that have been incorporated
into DNA so the secondary parietal layer
is basically these green dots that's one
lobe here's another lobe so
approximately half of the secondary
parietal cells we'll label in a two-hour
edu incubation so they're not
synchronous but they're at this stage
lots of the cells are getting ready to
do that very important peri clinal
division that makes the tepee demand
middle layer and in fact if you chart
that you see that the division at least
in the inbred we use is completely
symmetric so the final volume of the two
cell types
and and each of their dimensions are
identical so it's a very clonal division
that's perfect in is the term used in
the literature it makes two equivalent
cells okay so now we've we've made the
tippy-toe cells back here and their
first key job after some period of rapid
proliferation for a couple of days is
they secrete the palace that remodels
the kalos that's been secreted by the
pollen mother cells so the pollen other
cells secrete excess kalos it's kind of
lumpy and weird-looking and the Cowley's
causes it to be a smooth coat that in
cases each pollen mother cell in a shell
kind of like an mmm
then during meiosis the Tepito cells
begin to synthesize the components of
the x i'm so those are the sporophytic
compounds that end up being placed on
pollen as it develops weirdly the
tippy-toe cells also become by nuclei
which is a feature in almost all
angiosperms that has no explanation why
not just be polyploid no they've got to
have two nuclei and they also remodel
the wall that faces the developing
myocytes and subsequent micro
gametophyte s' and this wall remodeling
is extremely important for secretion
because at the end of meiosis they begin
to secrete these things that they've
been making and they do that through
this super elaborate plasma membrane
that perforates a wall that's now mostly
dissolved and then they do one last
thing for the anther about five days
later few days later they die program
cell death and those the collapse of the
remaining Tepito wall makes something
that we call biological velcro so each
developing micro gametophyte oops sorry
about that
each developing micro gametophyte needs
to find a place on this biological
Velcro so this is found in about 10% of
angiosperms where the micro gametophyte
sneed to attach to the dead tippy-toe
wall it's kind of like musical chairs if
you don't find a spot if you're left in
here you stop developing so it's an
absolute requirement to get viable
pollen that each and every one of these
microbe immuno fights get to one of
these two peed on landing pads so you
can see or I hope I've convinced you
that the peetam isn't just one thing
like to say it's a nutritive layer kind
of overlooks it the sequential jobs that
it performs this gave us a lot of
characters that we could use to judge
what's wrong in those dice or five
mutants
so by transmission
eeehm here's wild-type we see that the
tippy toe cells have two nuclei we could
see nuclei typically and they're really
dark staining they're filled with Xing
components whereas the Dicer five
mutants are very pale they're not making
exon and then also very clear this is a
special kind of microscopy analysis
called 3d segmentation where yellow
represents by nucleic cells and purple
mononuclear there's a lot more by
nucleus cells at various stages one and
a half for 2.5 millimeter in wild-type
Banyon immune so it appears that the
Dicer 5 mutant Tepito cells are failing
to different read if ur n she ate in a
timely fashion some make it some make by
nucleus cells which is one of the last
steps they might be accumulating a small
amount of X I'm but they're not normal
and so they're either delayed or
arrested in some aspect of their
developmental program
and then we did one more experiment
always the killer so we were writing all
of this up and we said wow you know we
always grow everything under really hot
conditions it's corn after all let's do
a low temperature experiment and see
what happens well the big surprise is
that the Dicer five mutants are restored
to partial or even full fertility when
grown under cool conditions so I need to
tell you that we were growing under
what's considered optimal corn yield
conditions there's huge historical data
that says you get maximum corn yield
with 28 to 29 centigrade days and 22
degree centigrade nights for us these
are restrictive conditions you
absolutely required I survive to be
present if you go under cool growing
conditions
Dicer five is dispensable so here's
mutant pollen from the cool growing
conditions here's the control pollen all
in is fine we can we have self
pollinated you can also see it here's in
warm growing conditions nice day here's
the period of meiosis when we made sure
that the temperature was really high and
we can get sterile plants if we lower
the temperature to 26 or 23 we get
fertility at least partial fertility now
it turns out that the cool growing
conditions do not restore the 24
nucleotide phases so Dicer 5 is not
being made under cool conditions
something else is going on not only that
but the ancient duplication parrot chain
Dicer 3 which is found in all flowering
plants can't substitute for Dicer 5 in
making the 24 nucleotide Pazzis
so what's dispensable are the fazzy
rnase not just ice or five you don't
need bazi RNAs for fertility if you grow
the plants in unusually cool conditions
and we did a long series of temperature
shift experiments in three day
increments this is a very complicated
slide the orange area is the period of
meiosis and we were shifting plants
between 21 or 23 degrees and 28 and then
back again and it turns out that I need
to tell you that developing maize tassel
has about seven days worth of antler
development and so to get a fully
fertile tassel where all of the anthers
come out you need our nine day treatment
six or nine day treatment but for any
given cohort of anthers that are of a
similar stage you only need three days
maybe less so there's a fee no critical
period during meiosis during the period
when the cioppino cells begin their read
if ur enchi ation when they either need
the fazzy 24 nucleotide RNAs or they
need cool conditions now what else does
cool conditions do it really slows down
development so meiosis is now going to
take 12 or 13 days instead of six or
seven and that also means the two petal
cells have a lot longer time to do
whatever they need to do to read if ur n
she ate okay so let's get to the
conclusions here so what can we say
about whether 21 nucleotide fazzy RNAs
are required for Mason through
development when we eliminate them
genetically and now we've eliminated
them by mutating micro RNA to one one
eight we fail to get normal somatic
development and this causes meal
stability so we can say it's possible
that the mobile signal under the
control of OC l4 is in fact the fazzy
rnase and that's the hypothesis that
we're trying to test now this green
arrow points to the part of each antler
lobe that is seems to be the most
important area for the expression of ocl
for for micro RNA two one one eight and
some of the other biogenesis factors
although there's no meristem maybe this
is a kind of signaling center in that
you've got information from here and it
spreads here the lobe and helps organize
the development of the soma what about
the 24 nucleotide RNAs
so if we eliminate Dicer 5 under normal
growing conditions and hence eliminate
the 24 nucleotide Fazzio rnase we get
male sterility but it seems to be not
sterility from some defect in meiosis
but from this important tip Edel celery
differentiation which seems contingent
under normal growing conditions on the
presence of the 24 nucleotide Fozzie's
so we're kind of left with a hypothesis
that in some way 24 a nucleotide fazzy
rnase aid rapid reorganization of
Torpedo cells so under normal growing
conditions the tippy-toe cells need to
do things
bang-bang-bang over a day to maybe 3 and
that that is helped by having 24
nucleotide fazzy RNA is present but if
you slow everything down then more or
less successfully the tippy-toe cells
can reorganize themselves using a
different pathway now this leads exactly
into my last slide which is we have yet
to pop the cork on this champagne
because of course the most important
thing to figure out is what are the
functions the exact functions of these
small RNAs so they could be acting in
some unexpected way as signals for cell
fate and differentiation I mean there's
many many examples of individual micro
RNAs
acting critical junctures to guide or
program differentiation why would you
need four hundred and forty twenty one
nucleotide low sigh why a hundred and
seventy that make twenty four nucleotide
passes so if their signals their
individually pretty crummy at it needs
ilion's of them they could have
cytoplasmic or nuclear roles or both or
pretty convinced now they're made in the
cytoplasm but they're not probably
restricted to that compartment and then
our sort of current working model I've
nicknamed the flak hypothesis so this is
also been suggested by some people that
work on the million PI rnase if you
accept that small RNA metabolism is
critical for cell differentiation then
disrupting it by putting out a huge
number of non-functional small rnas
could disrupt everything about small RNA
control so it might allow for making a
clean slate like when a cell needs to
change from one state to another like
from a primary parietal cell to an endo
these--oh and secondary parietal cell or
when the tippy-toe cells need to read if
ur n she ate if you don't have them
maybe there's a workaround like the
decay of the fazzy RNAs and eventually
the regular systems takeover and micro
RNAs can do their normal job anyway I
realize that's not a super satisfying
final hypothesis but it's what we're
working on now with new methods to knock
out not just one or two phase low side
but dozens if not hundreds at a time
okay and then it wouldn't be a good
seminar if I didn't acknowledge the
people who actually did the work so in
my lab there's a number of postdoctoral
fellows who have contributed to this
plus John Fernandez a bioinformatician
and then former members of the lab like
karina bender linda developed the Trojan
horse various other people worked on
aspects of the talk I gave today
and for the past five years and now
continuing for four more where
generously supported by the NSF in a
collaboration with like Meyer slab he's
expert his lab is expert on small RNA
sequencing and analysis so I have to say
we do a lot of the biology they do all
the sequencing and together we try to
figure out what's going on in these
answers thank you very much
[Applause]
differentiation oh yeah despite well no
they they kind of catch up with
everything it just takes a really long
time because the exon is formed on the
pollen like all the things that you
would expect to come to the tip Edom
eventually happen but actually pollen
shed even if it's only like a six day
period in cool weather
it'll the pond shed will be ten days
later than normal so you've really
extended developmental time between the
payara needs and mammals including the
synthesis from customers that factors
here for biome Genesis are leading to
male sterility right I'm wondering if in
the BC l5 you have reactivation of
mobile elements well on the first I can
say for sure there's appears to be no
reactivation of transposons this is true
for the Drosophila PI's and for a subset
about 10% of the mammalian PI RNAs are
well are associated with some homology
to some transposons what we seem not to
have that at all and then on the DNA
methylation front we have what I would
say is ambiguous data on whole anthers
so a postdoc now is doing laser micro
dissection of Tepito cells since that
seems to be where the action is to ask
if fazzy 20 force can influence the
level of methylation I think it's gonna
be technically challenging because the
by nucleate status requires one round of
DNA synthesis and so there's actually
you know it's not just one nucleus in
one cell what if there's like an old
nucleus and a new one you might say like
for them if you were Hemi methylated at
the beginning maybe you have one cell
that retains semi methylation and one
that's unmethylated because it got the
unmethylated so I'm guessing that this
is not going to be easy like to be
really definitive on but it's her
favorite theory because classically 24
nucleotide small RNAs and plants are
involved in the RNA directed DNA
methylation pathway and so it would be
something that you know a lot more is
known about that from the non fazzy 24
nucleotide class but i think pinning it
down here is going to be tricky the the
at the time when it matters
about 40% not quite 40% of all the
nuclei in an anther actually from the
Tepito that's why we have what I would
call hint of success results on whole
anthers but not really satisfying I
think we need the purified cells and
thank the speaker again this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu